as soon as the Sun Goes Down and the
beers are chilled it all gets going one
of the most traditional Samba parties in
Rio de Janeiro hundreds of people come
to the and RIE district every Monday
this is where they play the classics
it's wonderful I love some bye come here
every week I'm Argentinean and moved
especially to Rio because I can't live
without samba
you can sense the African origins of
Samba but here we're all mixed why black
it doesn't matter
Samba is a central part of Brazilian
culture but it wasn't always like that
the rhythm of the Samba embodies the
spirit of black culture of the slaves in
Brazil comes from the slums it grew
there and this is where Sambas heart
beats the 68 year old grew up in the
Moho door and rie favela it was a
difficult youth full of drugs and
violence fifty years ago Padrino
composed his first Samba song here about
suffering and longing most of his
friends from that time are now long dead
they meow meow Juventud back then I
threw my heart and soul into the music
and in return Samba and the community
pulled me out of a very bad place you
some more ska music blending many have
managed to free and save themselves
through Samba in 1962 he founded the
samba school Flor de Mena at the foot of
the hill he still visits regularly
tonight and there'll be some serious
drumming
[Music]
the samba school remains the center of
the community even today more than a
thousand inhabitants take part dancing
and performing in the carnival parades
Padrino is president of Rio's fourth
carnival league
[Music]
I'll die someday everybody else will too
but the samba will live on for 200-300
years as long as there's life they'll be
samba
and between yos music to will also live
on in the world of samba